your motivation sucks because your
environment sucks you're struggling
day-to-day to stay motivated to get on
top to get fired up for the day because
everything in your environment is
centered around you staying exactly
where you are instead of pushing you
towards discomfort and until you fix
that until you change your environment
until you're in an environment that is
inspiring and pushes you forward you're
never gonna get the growth in one year
from today if you do not change your
environment you will stay in the exact
same position with zero momentum and
zero growth when I was 18 years old I
made one small change to my environment
that dramatically changed the course of
my life I had just come back from Paris
I had met a girl in Paris that I wanted
to ask out but I was too chicken to do
it and so I took a picture as she was
walking away from me and I took that
picture and I blew it up and put it on
my wall just like I have these pictures
on my wall at that time it was a picture
of this beautiful French Riverside and
that was a picture for me that reminded
me on a daily that I did not want to
live the rest of my life in regret that
was a change in my environment that
pushed me to this comfort that the next
time I had an opportunity to do
something but I was afraid to do it I
would fast-forward my life to age 90 and
look back and say will I regret not
having taken action that visual that I
walked in and saw every single day was a
constant reminder for me and that's the
beauty of having an environment that's
designed for your success because it
only takes one day of taking action
these pictures all mean something to me
when I walk into this office and gets me
inspired it gets me feeling believing if
you walked into this office this may not
mean much to you but all of these people
mean something to me I had to set that
up one time and now every time when I
walk into my office I get inspired and
so after a few months of having that
picture up on my wall when I was 18
years old I got an opportunity to go
join a new startup company and it was
the opportunity to either be with that
startup make $300 a month being owner in
the business or go get my dream job that
I thought I always wanted and because I
had that record on repeat because by
looking at that picture every single day
I had that record on repeat in my mind
that I do not
want to live my life in regret I do not
want to regret the actions not taken in
my life that I had to examine that
decision should I join the startup or
should I go take my dream job dream job
and you know what I thought I could
always go and get another job like that
again it may not be the perfect job
meant to be that same job but I can
always get a job like that again I don't
know if I'll ever get that opportunity
to be an entrepreneur again I don't know
if this kind of opportunity will ever
show up again and I would regret not
taking action on being an entrepreneur
and so because I had that picture in my
environment every single day looking at
that picture every single day happening
around me every single day it pushed me
towards discomfort it forced me to do
the thing that was actually in my best
interest even though my brain would have
acted against me would have told me that
go do the safe thing the smart thing the
thing that I thought I always wanted and
so when you set up your environment
correctly it forces you it pushes you
towards discomfort towards the thing
that is in your best interest and
prevents you from acting against
yourself I always believe in volume is
more powerful your willpower who you
surround yourself matters what content
you consume matters rise and shine it's
expresso time what's up belief nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message set
wealth triggers
over to you Dan Locke so you notice I
have a lot of wealth triggers in my
office and so it's not just decorative
item everything means something too
right
so I have like you know the llk debt
stock that represents personal branding
yeah so I can think about that like
leadership energy and your shirt wisdom
so everything that's dead in my office I
wanted to call them wealth triggers yeah
you should this [ __ ] create certain type
of feeling environment for me right I
always believe in volume is more
powerful yeah your your willpower right
and what is 30 so I have meetings you
all time that's all sir every week goes
yeah yeah and then have the Chinese kind
of Friday in there yeah I'll see if I
can translate that basically means a
kind of like the autumn walk and battles
one before they were fought right and
your decisions affect affect with the
the outcome of the battle even your like
thousand miles away right let's rush me
out that's cool I like the katadyn yeah
yeah okay so how do you do it how do you
set up an environment for success I'm
gonna give you three things to do step
number one is fix your walls your desks
and your screens think about what's on
your wall what is on your wall where you
spend most of your time working this is
what's on my wall you can see it behind
me these all mean something deep and
powerful to me design your wall with
intention second what's on your desk so
for me I've got a bunch of things on my
desk you can see my wife my son my two
books I've got other books I've got
things on the desk that again inspire me
what is the thing that inspires you that
reminds you of your mission your one
word the thing that you don't want to
regret the thing that's gonna push you
towards discomfort on your desk as a
constant visual reminder and third there
is the screens so what is on your
desktop background what is on your phone
background what are the reminders every
time you load your phone there's that
message every time you look at your
computer there's that message fix your
walls your desk and your screens to have
an empowering message that you set up
once and inspires you for life step
number two is create an empowering
playlist make a playlist of your
favorite songs that get you up that get
you move in the get you bounce and they
get
feeling excited motivated energized what
ends up happening for a lot of people is
when they're feeling sad when they're
feeling low when they're feeling down
and hate in their life what do they do
you put on really sad music that's the
worst thing that you want to do you want
to flip it music is the fastest way to
change your state to go from a place of
feeling lethargic lazy low-energy
to feeling up energetic motivated pumped
up the fastest way to do it is through
music and so create a playlist for you I
have mine I call it my belief playlist
it's a public place you can find it on
my channel if you want to go and look at
it those are the songs that I listen to
when I need to get get my boost going
those are the songs I listen to first
thing in the morning those are the songs
that I have on at my office while I'm
working
not while I'm listening to YouTube
videos cuz gotta pay attention to the
words but otherwise if I'm doing normal
kind of boring menial tasks I got that
music on it's pumping me up and fire me
up and so there's no one song that's
gonna work for everybody you already
know the songs that make you feel alive
bold moving your body so make a playlist
set it up once and then you can put that
playlist on repeat and shuffle the song
so that you have a daily consistent hit
of inspiration in your ears and step
number three is change your wardrobe if
you watching this video day and has a
suit Dan likes walking around in the
suit it makes them feel powerful and
special and makes them think of money
and wealth which is what he's trying to
accomplish I love it for me this is my
suit this is my wardrobe I feel like
Batman putting this on I had these
custom design hoodies where these ones
have the special things for the thumb
and the other ones have the orange
inside of the hood and the orange
underneath the arm that that makes me
feel awesome wearing those things and do
I need them to be successful no but I
love putting them on I'm putting on my
Batman suit when I go to work every day
now maybe to you that means nothing
maybe this this is the nastiest thing
you've ever seen in your life awesome
what is the Wardrobe that makes you come
alive that when you put this on it's
time to go to work it's time to crush
your mission it's time to have the most
productive day of all time and so you're
not sitting around in your pajamas
feeling lazy slow lethargic you're going
to work you're putting your Batman
soo-dong changing your wardrobe what
does that look like for you so remember
when you change your environment it's
the ultimate motivational brain hack
because motivation for most people you
have to wake up and get inspired by
watching the video or reading the book
taking some kind of action but when you
change the environment around you it's a
one time thing that sets you up for life
because you're always walking to this
office and you can always play that
music you can always put on that
wardrobe
so my question today for you is what
simple change would you make to your
environment right now let me know put in
the comments below
I'm getting more and more intrigued by
mindset because I used to think of it as
fluffy like self-help and now I think it
more as strategy what's your strategy in
life somebody asked me on Instagram
after I posted a scary if the mindset
has been skewed how can you bring it
back and I answered with by surrounding
yourself with people who have the
mindset you aspire to my friends please
understand that mindset is controllable
in the same way that all our opinions
are controllable the key is to add more
people with optimism and cut people with
negativity it's very very simple now
it's very hard to cut people with
pessimism cynicism and negativity when
they are the people that are no closest
to you parents siblings spout but the
bottom line is if you're asking the
question I'm gonna give you the answer
the answer is add more people with
positivity and optimism and cut people
with pessimism and cynicism who you
surround yourself matters what content
you consume matters I basically
suffocate myself for a long period of my
time and created an environment that was
based on offense and optimism and now I
know no different please do the same for
you make that move mold and I mean mold
your mindset by what you consume and
with whom you consume it I would argue
that for some of the people in this
audience are here today because they
worry about the way they would be judged
by one
[Music]
if you're not feeling it find new
friends I'm being dead serious
this one is real game Tariq who you hang
out with is a huge ionica these are all
trying true things right we've heard the
you're the whatever of the five friends
you spent like that's real I'm one new
winner friend like you know what I mean
had one new winner friend and got one
loser friend like yeah I know he's being
a boy from fourth grade but makes me -
please - ko me like you can only love
them so much
if you're going to Paul TK TDC if you go
into finance New York movies probably
still LA and antic is Silicon Valley has
an aspect that's that's very open very
fluid and and it helps tremendously on
these cutting-edge ideas you want to be
in the place where you can talk to as
many people as possible about your ideas
on because that's the way you will know
that they're cutting edge and you will
improve them even more hi this is Dan
lock if you're a fan of Evans work if
you want to know exactly how the model
my success I want to invite you to join
me for a special online training all you
have to do is click on a link below you
can join me for absolutely no charge so
click on link below and I will see you
in class if you want more Dane Locke
check out the top ten rules video I made
on him I think you'll enjoy it the link
is right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there that
experience change how I operate and that
that's hard about this hunger to learn
yeah as much as I could